Smash. And this Sunday I heard the far
right thugs, the cows, the intellectual
midrits. Okay. Some of them are sincere.
I'm not all like that. I'll come and
speaker corner. I'll see you there. Come
to be with these questions all day,
every day. Yes. This Sunday, I'll be
there. Come and let's have an
intellectual discussion if you got the
guts.
I'm so happy to be able to talk to you
[music] today. And mashallah my brother
our sheikh Ali Hammuda is doing a great
job. Work forever is a very very uh
beautiful cause [music] because the
reward of what you give is not just at
the moment of giving but rather it is
prolonged for a very very long time
[music] and it lasts for as long as that
work continues [snorts]
to generate to generate some form
[music] of benefit. So I highly
recommend Walk Forever as an ambassador
of Abdullah Aid. I know the the uh
partnership that we have is amazing
[music] and uh not many people
understand the concept of wak [music]
yet the reward is far greater through
the wak. So inshallah if you can support
what forever [music]
uh it will be really really amazing and
very very rewarding.
>> Let's car let's watch the video
inshallah of this so-called im. I don't
think he's an im. I'm just saying he's
an imam. But anyway, let's watch a
false.
>> What's your name?
>> My name is Omar.
>> Omar.
>> Yeah.
>> Omare. We're obviously in Jerusalem.
>> We're just understanding the complexity
of the Jewish side and the Muslim side.
>> What's your view?
>> Complexity basically pay. He has to go
to the wheel and move with the cip.
Okay. Yes. Basically, yes. He's
registered, you know. He's very
unbiased. 100%. Okay. Brother, my friend
Aki Ome, this guy hates your guts, man.
Being around you hates you. He hates
your messenger. He is Allah subhana wa
ta'ala and look at the
lovely conversation. Your tone was so
collected. Look at the love you give
him. Yes. In Islam, the basic prince
were hating and loa for the sake of
Allah. Basic principle. Yes. Let's car.
If he was a Muslim, I'll be saying
something different.
>> He's a British Muslim on state of
Israel.
>> Um I have no issue as long as people are
living in peace. If they have their
side, they have their country and the
Palestinians have their own kind of safe
spot where they can live freely without
under any oppression or any injustice.
>> I'm so sorry. I'm very critical. They
can have their country and the
Palestinian somewhere they can live in
some place. Yeah. This is called an
infury complex. Brother, you're acting
like you as if you're worshiping, bro.
He's there as if he's your king. Yeah.
And you're No, this that these guys know
how we deal with them. Look at the
respect you're giving a dirt bag like
him. Yeah, Palestinians are being
massacred few kilometers away. Children
and babies and mothers and men are
buried, massacred. Alhamdulillah. Yes,
the Israelis have been destroyed on the
ground on the battlefield. They're being
annihilated, liquefied, liquidated
intellectually. The whole world has
woken up to reality. The whole world is
woken up to this dirt back to the Romans
and his own fans. Yes. But you are there
sucking up to him. Amaze him. I think
this is the solution for peace in the
Middle East. See,
>> I don't expect to hear that cuz I didn't
expect to hear many Muslims that would
recognize a a the Israeli state.
>> No, I have no issue. The Israelis,
they've been living here for thousands
of years.
>> You have no issue.
You have no issue. If I came and took
your house, Yes. and massacred wife and
kids and threw you into your shed and
said you can maybe liberally among you
with some cop, there's no issue. You
have no shame on you, man. Man, shame on
you is infiltr complex this big that
you're rumbling in front of it. Yeah,
there's why you tell the truth of what's
going on, man. If you don't know, why
are you talking? Why are you talking?
And uh if they want to live in this part
of the country in this part of the
region of the world and that they can't.
But what my uh what the issue of the
main Muslim majority population is as
long as they live in peace together, as
long as there's not this oppression and
injustice taking place, then we have no
problem.
>> What would you say? If you get
throughout Muslim history, you'll see
that when the crusaders came, then
Jewish people expelled from Jerusalem.
But when the Muslims ruled, then the
Christians, Muslims, and Jewish people
lived in peace and harmony.
>> There you go. Look, do you see that? He
can't do that to with me. Yes. Look,
look.
>> Long as they pay the J. Of course, as
long as they pay the tax, which we live.
>> Do you see? Do you see? Do you see? Do
you see? Look, look, look, look, look.
He look, let's debate and attack this.
Look, he you mentioned a fact, which is
true. If we're anti-semitic, why is it
that
and brought Jewish families when
Christians like you, Tommy and Liam,
tough? Tim, Liam, not tough. Okay, both
of you if you're Christians, okay, why
do you guys were massacring you
anti-semites? You guys realize sites
were massacring the Jews because of them
killing your god. Okay. All right. Um,
what was the Muslims? Muslims bring Jews
back in. Muslims, the Jews run to Muslim
protections for years and hand. But what
does he do instead of go to Jiza? He
made a good point. Hey, no, change the
topic. Go to Jiza. Even with the bro,
even with the Jiza, what's what's the
issue, man? It's indiscriminate. If
that's the case, why don't a cat? Why
does me and my wife have to pay as a
cat? Why J is a what? J is to protect
the minorities within an Islamic lands.
We have to fight for you. We have to go
out there for what? One dinar. You pay
you pay in your country. You pay 50
types of different tax, my friend. 50
types of different tax and you're
complaining about a which is what? Which
is there to serve you. Okay? If you
cannot fight, it's only for the fighting
men. That's for the children and for the
the kids. Only for the fighting men.
Zaka is something far expensive. 2 and a
half% of my will. If I own £100,000 a
year, I have to pay two and a half
grand. Okay? Far more than a is that
screaming to me. That's why they can't
come to us. That's why Liam tough, you
and Tom, I know you guys are going to
watching this. I challenge you guys, me
and Muhammad against any of you cronies.
You'll never come. You cowards, you'll
never come see Mr. Sunday. Let's see
what's going on.
>> As long as they were subjugated. No, as
long they live freely. If you read
history, they were they were there was
no there was no oppression. There was no
occupation providing they paid special
money for protection just like we do.
>> Yes. Exactly. What's your what's your
point? I don't understand. Every empire
had that. What's it? The Greeks had it.
The Romans, the Romans had it. What's
the point? Look at You see what I'm
saying? He knows it's the truth. What's
the issue of paying tax? Okay, stop.
Everybody pays tax. You pay more taxes.
I would prefer to pay it if I was a
non-Muslim. Understandable. Let me tell
you something. Jews were flocking to
Muslim lands and begging the Muslims.
Let's pay. The robbers are robbing us
blind. Okay? And alhamdulillah.
>> The Muslims didn't have to pay the same
tax. They also the Muslims have to pay
extra. They have to be zak towards
Muslims. No, that goes to the the the
community doesn't like it.
Make some good points. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah, exactly. See, do you see
this what I'm saying? You get caught,
you coward. That goes back to the That's
the same concept of taxes.
>> Can I Okay. Sorry. Can I ask you change
the topic? Made a good point. Change the
topic completely.
>> So, what would you say if I've just told
you I've walked along this shopping
street in the Muslim quarter? I've spoke
to many Muslim business owners who said
they love the state of Israel.
>> Yeah,
>> that's fine. That's that surprise you.
It surprised me.
>> I don't think so.
>> They said they're happy living here and
they haven't faced discrimination and
they feel fairly treated under the state
of Israel.
>> That's perfectly fine.
>> Yeah, exactly. You know, go to the West
Bank, you know. Yeah. Yeah. They've been
fairly treated, etc. Oh, 100%. I knew
it's coming from you. Hey, and by
yourself, we won't believe it so much.
He was radio shield. That's what you
are.
>> As long as they're happy, they're living
in peace and security. I see no issue
with this. And if they have no issue
with it, then I have no issue with it.
>> What's your name?
>> More Muslims like Amir. Yeah. [laughter]
>> No, I'm just obese, you know. I don't
like this fighting thing taking place.
Um,
>> what do you what can I ask you of you?
>> The British government just recognized
the state of Palestine.
>> I think that's a real
>> Okay. But the Palest So, the Palestinian
Authority who who control the state of
Palestine, they have a rule and a law
where they pay money to people from the
refugee camps, Muslims, to go and kill
Israelis. So, they reward people for
murdering innocent civilians. Is that a
good thing?
>> Of course not. Have you even fact
checked it, brother? Have you even asked
is this true or not?
You get what I'm saying? When you have
an infuri complex, you can't even
challenge. What he said is, oh yeah,
it's true. How do you know it's true,
bro?
>> How come we as a country recognize it?
>> Very clearly that the Quran says that to
kill one person is as you have killed
entire mankind. Can you save one person
is as if you have saved entire mankind.
Can you carry on reading that verse
enough?
>> I dare you to come to me with that
question. I dare you. You all of you far
come to me with that question, bro. Come
to me with that question, bro. Come. You
can't. you know you coward you can't you
go to people that don't know much okay
the brother alhamdulillah the only thing
good I would say there's some good
points he does as well was this
beautiful restitution and all this kind
of stuff other than that absolutely
humiliation and it gets worse
can I translate what you said unless
they cause mischief and they they must
have their hands and feet cut off and
exiled from the land
>> that that that that's not up to Tom
Dickar to decide that is up to a
qualified judge to decide and if you
look in Ottoman history you you'll find
very few scenarios where that actually
took place
>> can I ask who's who's Ib Kafir
Kir is a great mu and Muslim theology.
>> Is he very good? Is he recognized? Well,
Ibin translates the word mischief as
meaning not believing in Allah. Okay.
>> So that verse that you just quoted
>> see this is what I mean that is also a
meaning but means what? Not believing
Allah's means what? Waging war against
Allah's means what? This can be done by
Muslims. In inah in the Quran 49 verse 9
or 12 it said if there are two opposite
parts as Muslims one fight the other you
have to fight the fight fight fight
fight fight fight fight fight fight
fight the other one. Yes. So hold on a
second. Are they not calling mischief
against Allah's mas? Yes, they are.
Mischief can mean is mischief. That's
another meaning. This specific verse is
talking about who it's talking about
highways who came to the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him. They were
not well. They were ill and he sent him
to his shepherd to be get to get heal in
medicine and they went and execute
executed the innocent shepherd took his
eyes out, cut his tongue out. Yes. Okay.
And that's what Allah is talking about
in that specific words verse about those
people who have waged against war
against Allah's messenger. Mischief in
the land is not talking about nothing
about them being a Muslim or not Muslim
for that matter. And guess what? There
was a capital punishment for them.
What's your point? Capital punishment.
What is your point? But look what does
word that you just that verse that you
just translated according to that great
Islamic scholar translates that mischief
not believing in Allah must be punished
by death, execution.
>> That's his that's his opinion. No, if
you
>> you just said he's a great Islamic
scholar. He's one of the most renowned
in the world.
>> That doesn't mean I have to agree with
everything he says.
>> You see what I mean, brother? Go to any
scholar. Majority of the scholars
believe that Mr. is does mean he's also
mean or disbelieve in Allah who who
it's not any Tom, Dick, and Har. It's
not about that. Okay? It is talking
about the hostiles, hostile enemies of
Islam. Okay? It comes in different
forms. So he went there and making it
seem as if just because you are a
disbeliever that's nonsense because we
got clear verse in the Quran where Allah
said you cannot force step against their
will. Allah says and it's abregated it's
abated in 10 it says Allah does not
forbid you from being just and kind to
those who do not fight you based on your
fate.
>> Chapter 12 they can't do that with us
the cowards.
>> But do you understand why we have a
problem when millions
>> you as a as a as a human being I don't I
don't agree with majority of you of your
views but that doesn't mean I I don't
support your journalism. That doesn't
mean I agree with the work that you are
doing.
>> Okay.
But what I'm saying is, do you
understand? Do you understand why? If
we've got an Islamic scholar who's one
of the most renowned in the world, he
translates the verse that you just
quoted to say, "Kill non-Muslims."
>> Where does he say kill no Muslims? Where
does he say kill no Muslims? You see the
lie? When I confronted him, I asked him
this 20 times, show me a single verse
Allah said in the Quran, kill non Muslim
cuz they mean no Muslims.
>> But if if you look at if you look at see
one thing is what's on paper. If you
look at example of how the Islamic
society and Islamic uh caliphate ruled
in for the past 13 centuries, you'll
find that that isn't the case. What
about the ISIS caliphate?
>> We don't agree with that at all. We that
is
>> What sector are you from, sir?
>> I'm a Sunni.
>> You're a Sunni?
>> Yes. Okay.
>> The ISIS caliphate was not I can't even
call it a caliphate. That was completely
against the Quran and Sunnah. Everything
that they did is completely against. And
I can see freely and openly that they
are very they are not Muslims at all.
>> Even Hamas Hamas they um some of the
teachings that they propagate and some
of the things they have carried out is
against Muslim teachings.
>> Are you an imam?
>> Yes, I am an imam.
>> Moskin in Leicester.
>> Nottingham.
>> In Nottingham.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. [snorts]
>> Interesting chat. And uh I I do I follow
you on social media quite a lot and I
for your patriotism I think what
patriotism bro he's got he supports
Israel his own followers of reada he
supports Israel more than his own
country British aid workers of gond got
massacred and he was laughing about it a
patriot yeah he puts if he puts Israeli
football club before his own country I
think that you have maybe got the wrong
picture and the wrong version of Islam
podcast I have Muslim friends in growing
up in Luton and I think the correct You
see the area where you have grown up in
was mainly is it Pakistani Kashmir
Muslim Pakistani Kashmir and are you
Indian?
>> Yes I am. Yes.
>> And you'll notice that the Gujarati the
generally they are more kind of
welcoming and they are less inclined to
this kind of violence and security.
>> Back to Bleiji Jamaat the mosque. Yes.
>> He threw Iban Kafir the Palestinian
under the bus. Iban Kafir under the bus.
The good are under the busi
I mosque. No, I don't I'm not part of
the group, but I know people that are
part of the group.
>> Okay.
>> What about Alawa and
>> what are the squists to the abund
who's who's person who
>> um people like them? I don't really have
any inclination towards those kind of
people. I don't really agree what they
kind of do, you know, going out to the
streets and um forcing people and you
know be aggressive. I've seen some of
his his videos. He can be quite
aggressive. That kind of approach I
don't I'm more of a gentle person. I
like talking to people.
>> You're a gentle person? Yeah. Okay.
Which video? Can you one second? Can you
point to me which video of mine I have
being uh forceful to a non-Muslim or
being uh aggressive to someone who
hasn't been aggressive to Allah and his
messenger? Give me one scenario but of
somebody who hasn't come to me hostile
and I just look at all my D videos. I've
got thousands. Show me any brother.
Shame on you. Forget me. Wall be to you.
I wish that you that whole video was you
insulting me. I wish it was you
insulting me. nothing but me and in well
I'll take it insulting me except
throwing the Palestinians the resistance
yes throwing Iban Kafir the Gujaratis
the Obandis everyone indirectly okay he
threw everyone under the bus those
Palestinians who are buried 60,000
innocent men massacred and you are here
appeasing this bastard dog yeah this
anger you're talking about yes I have it
for Allah I have it Yes, I have it for
the enemies of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and his messenger. I am angry for the
sake of Allah subhana wa ta'ala. You
know why? Cuz my religion calls for it.
You are born Muslim, bro. You're an
imam. I came to Islam. I'm not saying
I'm better than you. You are probably
much better than me in this instance.
I'm I hate your actions for the sake of
Allah, bro. An enemy of Islam standing
in front of you talking. You shake his
hand. Hey, buddy. D. Yes. And then what
you do? Criticize everybody.
Palestinians. Yeah, they need just some
place. You don't talk about the
oppression, the massacre of the men and
their children. And then you come and
say, "Ali, who man to hell with Ali
Dawa? Who cares about Ali Dawa? It's not
about me. It's about the principle,
bro." And then what do you do? You go
and take a selfie. That guy who despises
you, who hates you, he's taking a selfie
with you. You're taking a selfie with
him. If someone assaulted your mother,
Yes. who is our auntie, our sister, we
will not let anybody say any word. If
someone assaulted your mother, would you
take selfie with them? But you yet you
take a selfie with an enemy of Allah
when Allah tells you hate for the sake
of Allahh who people who are hostile who
justify the killing of innocent men,
women and children and you're here
casually talking to Yeah. I'm I'm angry.
I am angry.
Yes. And alhamdulillah Islam is going
and never going to stop Islam. That's
not the issue. It's sad to see this and
I want to make this clear category
clear. Any of you ignorants who think
that you can go and try to harm this
Muslim man, you you listen, fear Allah,
we're for the sake of Allah. Yes, that's
what it is. But other than that, this
brother is our brother. He's still our
brother, but he should know and this had
to be done. So do not ever dare to harm
this brother or his family. Yes. May
Allah forgive him. All I want to say is
just shame on you. Shame on you, bro.
That's all I can say. And I hope you
don't listen. We're all human beings. We
all make mistakes. I make mistakes. Seek
Allah's forgiveness, inshallah. Yes. And
to the far right, if you guys are
watching this Sunday, I speak his
corner. If you guys have the test
testical fortitude, come and see me,
bro. Come and see me like a man. Let's
talk about, let's debate, bring all of
this stuff. I'm going to intellectually
decimate you guys, rinse you guys. Okay?
Come Sunday for a discussion. I'll be
there. I don't want to have this
anymore.
Goodbye.